our entire first few months of dating
was just I'm gonna work all day you can
work next to me that was what we did
from the day we met and this really
hasn't changed we went from like first
date until today with very little
changing in our relationship you know
when someone laughs and they're like
you're stupid she said that to me once I
was like I just don't like being called
stupid even if it's a joke and she was
like okay never did it again if you
define learning as same condition new
Behavior like if you haven't changed
your behavior with the same condition
you have not learned and intelligence is
speed of learning which is speed of
behavior change my marriage is atypical
this is just what has worked for us is
that I like working all the time and I
wanted someone who would work all the
time with me because if I didn't then I
wouldn't see them and then we would
drift apart because I'm getting way
different stimuli from my life than they
are and inherently we're going to adapt
to the things that we're exposed to all
day and eventually we'll look at each
other be like oh we don't know each
other and some people that's exciting to
me you might as well be a stranger and I
can just keep doing my own thing